how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU today we have a very very
interesting plot League for the one
division series one that sounds very
very real and one that has been taken
down off of some sites which gives it a
little bit of validity now over the past
few days it seems like some of the
episodes of the one division series or
their scripts have been leaked because
there have been a lot of different plot
looks online the past few days talking
about multiple different aspects of the
show all believed to be from these
leaked episodes that are online and
basically what we have here today is a
lot of information about the first three
episodes about the one division series
and a lot of information about what's
going to happen later on in this season
and possibly bleed into season 2 as well
and like I said before there's a chance
that this could be very very real it's
written very well and the leak has been
taken off of some websites which give it
validity so this could be real and if
that is the case I have to issue a
spoiler alert if you were trying to
avoid any and all things about the Wan
division series coming to Disney Plus
you should click away now if you're here
be sure to subscribe to stay up to date
on everything relating to the MCU and to
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win an exclusive Ironman a Funko pop
all you have to do is subscribe like the
video and comment about the video down
below so like I said we'll go through
the first league talking about the first
three episodes and then into another
plot leak right after the main story is
a doctor who got snapped an infinity war
trying to enter a multiverse reality to
be with his dead wife and daughter the
first scene is of Bruce Banner and Hank
Pym giving a talk at a university Neil
deGrasse Tyson cameos and they're
talking about the plot of endgame and
time-travel opening of the multiverse
they take some questions and one
question that is asked is what is to
stop them from doing it again Hank Pym
says that he destroyed his Pym particles
and Bruce Banner says that he destroyed
the machine and blueprints so nobody
could recreate what they did so remember
that one division is going to bleed into
Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness everything is going to lead up
to what happens in that movie so right
away we're setting up the multiverse in
the MCU they're just coming right out
and saying hey there is a multiverse now
the events of Avengers endgame created
and of course as you can see people are
wondering can you do it again and the
main story is about a doctor asking that
question so he can go be with his dead
wife and daughter so the first scene
sets up the multiverse but then we go to
Wanda who was in France living off the
grid she has a totally different look
different hair different clothes and she
has a job on a farm taking phone calls
she lives in a suburban apartment and
one night she's drinking and it's
implied that she hasn't used her powers
since AVENGERS endgame but one night she
uses her powers to create an image of
vision next to her and he says some
lines from Civil War and infinity war
like I only fill you and it's supposed
to be her memory of him but then he says
find me and Wanda freaks out and ends
the image she goes to bed crying the
next morning sword shows up and it's
Monica Rambeau the little girl from
Captain Marvel Wanda has been avoiding
sword for the past few months but agrees
to go with them she makes a getaway bag
full of cash and clothes and hides it
under her bed then she goes to the cafe
and they explained that they need to
reassemble the most powerful Avengers
for the next I knows level threat Wanda
says that she's not ready and they tell
her to think about it but they do say
they need her to come to the u.s. with
them soon she agrees and she goes home
but while she was out the doctor from
the first scene had snuck into her
apartment and stolen her cash he was
following sword without them realizing
Wanda goes home grabs her bag and then
goes to the train station she gets on
the train and when someone comes for her
ticket she tries to give it to him but
she doesn't have any cash the doctor
shows up and hands the ticket taker cash
and says he's got her ticket she thinks
him and he sits with her he says that he
recognizes her but he won't say anything
as she clearly doesn't want to be found
they start talking and he tells her he
made a facility in the Midwest to
support snap and blip victims who
couldn't psychologically handle it and
he's in Europe meeting with potential
patients at a hospital he says that it's
an inpatient facility and people live
there but it's confidential and people
can leave whenever they want he says
that he knows that she got snapped
because she was famous and he wants to
help her heal so she agrees and gets off
the train with him and goes with him to
his private jet he takes her to his
facility which is almost a quarter mile
long and looks like an apartment complex
people have balconies and lived normal
lives for the most part but live at the
facility he gives her a room and sets
her up with a psychiatrist in the lobby
she meets
few other people who were staying at the
facility she meets a guy whose kid died
between the snap and the blip so when he
bled back they had been gone for a few
years now she then meets a widow who the
leak says is played by Kathryn Hahn and
it's widely believed to be that she is
plain Agatha Harkness
Wanda talks a little bit about herself
but she spares a lot of details because
they don't appear to know who she is she
has her first appointment with the
psychiatrist and is reluctant to give
details but the doctor tells her that
everything is confidential and nobody
knows she's there so they just talk
about things that make her happy and
Wanda says that the last time she was
truly happy was when she was a kid with
her brother and they would watch
American sitcoms the doctor tells her
that she can get some old shows on video
and give them to Wanda she gives Wanda
Brady Bunch
Roseanne and Boy Meets World with a few
others as well Wanda goes back to her
apartment and watches some of the old
shows as it flashes back to her and
Quicksilver as kids watching the same
episode and that's the end of the first
episode the second episode starts with
dr. Smith driving his car in the highway
him and his wife are taking their
daughter to her dance studio and he
starts to snap the wife grabs the wheel
as he is disappearing and crashes into
an oncoming car dr. Smith blips back
with a bunch of other people on the side
of the highway and everyone is really
confused
normal people start honking at them and
everybody gets out of their cars and
then the title plays
Wanda goes to lunch at a place in the
facility and she meets Darcy from Ford
she's there because she snapped and
blipped and her boyfriend got cancer
during the five years when she was
blipped and he ended up dying she tried
to find him when she blitt back but she
was too late so she has bad guilt and
PTSD due to her connection with Thor and
the Avengers she knows who Wanda is but
she says that she won't tell anybody
Jimmy woo from ant-man is looking at
security footage of dr. Smith at a gas
station by his private landing strip in
the Midwest dr. Smith winks at the
camera and shoots it with a paintball
gun from his truck he goes backwards in
the video using the license plate and
sees it at the landing strip and he
searches dr. Smith's plane ID number and
calls Interpol
Wanda goes to her second session with
the psychiatrist and they talk about the
shows that she watched the other night
she asked if anything made her feel
close to that happiness in her adult
life that she had as a kid Wanda says
yes but she can't talk about it the
doctor agrees and says that it's only
been a year since the blip and a lot of
people are only start
to talk about their traumas one the
leaves and dr. Smith comes in another
door and asked the doctor how Wanda is
the doctor says that Wanda is opening up
a bit but it could be days months nobody
knows Smith tells the doctor to try and
trigger Wanda in the next session by
talking about vision and the doctor
agrees Wanda meets Agatha Harkness and
Darcy in the restaurant again after her
session and they have dinner together
they go back to Wanda's apartment and
watch some Brady Bunch
they talk about their experiences and
how they wish there was a way to bring
their lovers back Kathryn Hans character
is actually somebody who has been
planted there although it's not yet
revealed in the episode but she starts
to ask Wanda about her boyfriend but
Wanda doesn't say much
Darcy distracts Kathryn Hans character
by making jokes and they all drink and
then leave for the night we then have
another flashback of dr. Smith he's at
his old house right after the blip
people are still freaking out and
celebrating and he knocks on the door
and it's another family they say they
got the house from the bank during the
bad times because the whole family
snapped dr. Smith couldn't find his wife
at the highway so he goes to the library
and uses their computer to search for
her and his daughter where he finds out
that they died in the car accident he
breaks down crying in the library he
then goes to the University that he used
to work at and they all celebrate seeing
him and a few other colleagues they talk
about the hospital that is housing
people in the Midwest for people with
snap related PTSD and that he should
transfer there and he does we then go
back to Wanda having another session
with her psychiatrist and Juana says
that she's finished all of the Brady
Bunch
and it brought back a lot of memories
they talked about how she's fitting in
and Wanda talks about the girls that
she's made friends with the doctor is
happy and tells her to pursue
friendships even if they don't match up
to the Avengers and vision Wanda gets
really upset and the doctor consoles her
but Wanda storms out and starts packing
her bags in her apartment Kathryn Hahn
comes by but Wanda says that she knew
they just wanted her for her connection
to her old life and she's going to leave
Kathryn Hahn comes her down and tells
her that she should go talk to Smith
about it
Wanda eventually calms down and agrees
it ends with Jimmy woo looking at
footage of the plane and France and
rewinds it to see dr. Smith getting off
the train with Wanda although he doesn't
recognize Wanda but he then puts in the
next tape and it's footage of dr. Smith
getting on the train in Wanda's old
hometown
he sees sword agents in the background
running after the train leaves the
station and he says huh I wonder why
they are there and that's the end of the
second episode but as I mentioned we do
have a little bit more information about
some characters and this is another plot
leak that has been taken down it says
that Agatha Harkness really is a witch
from the Salem witch trials she ends up
revealing this tawanda and helps her
learn to control her powers and create
different realities however like the
previous leak said she's actually
planted there by somebody and here it
said that Agatha Harkness works for a
very powerful mysterious villain now she
creates a new reality with vision and
Agatha Harkness is there in that reality
with her as well she eventually gets
pregnant and gives birth to the twins
Wiccan and speed they also are gifted
with magical powers and Agatha helps
train them as well but then it said that
vision gets possessed by the demon
mephesto and that's all we really know
but it is safe to assume that Agatha is
working for mephesto now Agatha for the
most part is good in the comics but she
does have a pretty deep connection with
mephesto now if all of this ends up
being true what's really interesting is
how they build the show up they don't
dive right into Wanda creating different
realities and creating a new family
where visions involved they start off
very slowly and develop a very deep plot
the different realities that we know are
coming due to the teaser that we got
from Disney plus they come later and I
have to say that if this does in fact
end up being true then I like the way
that they're doing this because of Wanda
creating an image of vision and him
speaking to her find me that could mean
that he could truly come back and not
just exist in a different reality that
Wanda creates but let me know what you
think about this if this ends up being
true is this something that you would
like to see from the series well let me
know what you think in the comments down
below and don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you can stay up to date
on everything relating to the MCU for
live updates you can follow me on
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
you